être invités politiques ce matin c'est
Bruno Retailleau bonjour Bruno
Retailleau merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous ce matin sénateurs de la Vendée
président du groupe les républicains ici
au Sénat on est ensemble pendant un
petit peu plus de 20 minutes pour un
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Julien lecuyé
de la Voix du Nord bonjour Julien
bonjour
Yannick évidemment parler de la réforme
des retraites Bruno Retailleau mais est
d'abord un mot sur l'actualité puisque
l'Allemagne a donné son feu vert à
l'envoi de Charlot léopard en Ukraine
Joe Biden a annoncé que les États-Unis
allaient eux livrer 31 chars Abrams
est-ce que la France doit livrer des
chars Leclerc moi je crois pas je ne le
pense pas d'un point de vue stratégique
la France a des moyens et le fait
d'épauler l'Ukraine nous l'avons fait
d'ailleurs avec la livraison d'une
trentaine de chars légers qu'on appelle
les amx-10rc mais l'Ukraine va se
retrouver avec trois dotations 14
challengers 2 britannique pour l'instant
par léopard 2 donc allemand puis des
Abrahams américains à chaque fois que
vous multipliez l'été régionalité du
matériel vous complexifier les chaînes
logistiques un exemple le char par
exemple britannique et un fût
particulier et du coup les munitions
sont aussi particulières si vous ajoutez
une quatrième catégorie vous avez un
problème vis-à-vis de l'emploi de cet
arbre ce qui veut dire et je l'ajoute on
a un autre problème en France c'est que
on a que à peu près 200 chars vous
rendez compte la Finlande pour donner un
exemple un petit pays dispose de 200
léopards donc nous on est à l'os donc on
se démunirait sans pour autant
contribuer de façon décisive des 200
chars mais j'allais dire c'est même pire
que ça puisque selon les chiffres qu'on
a c'est 200 qui sont en or rénovation
d'ici 2030 donc autant dire que si même
on devait en donner quelques-uns on en
aurait plus d'une centaine opérationnel
donc je pense que dans ce débat là c'est
un faux débat je pense que il va y avoir
de charges j'observe d'ailleurs si on
veut vraiment que l'Ukraine soit aidé en
matière de blinder lourd il faut sans
doute un corps blindé c'est-à-dire deux
brigades blindée mécanisé c'est
120 150 chars pour être un peu efficace
je pense que l'Allemagne va donner je
crois 14 chars lourds léopards 2 mais la
communauté c'est-à-dire les pays qui
disposent de ces mêmes chars il y en a
12 et il y en a sans doute pas loin de
2000 en Europe donc c'est là en réalité
qu'on a des stocks qui peuvent permettre
de faire quelque chose pour l'Ukraine
monsieur c'est vrai que vous pointez
l'efficacité finalement militaire de de
la chose mais est-ce qu'on doit craindre
aussi par la livraison de ces arbres une
escalade et j'en veux pour preuve aussi
la volonté de Zelinski de recevoir des
missiles longues portées des chasseurs
est-ce que on risque d'entrer là encore
dans une escalade militaire ce que vous
dites est très juste je viens je pense
que d'abord moi je suis c'est dubitatif
sur le fait que une centaine de
charlourds même les plus récents
occidentaux puissent vraiment changer la
donne je suis vraiment très très partagé
en revanche ce que je sais c'est que on
doit assumer le bras de fer avec
Monsieur Poutine force doit rester au
droit international et de ce point de
vue là les grands démographies
occidentales ne doivent pas faiblir ne
doivent pas céder en revanche en
revanche il faut aider l'Ukraine sans
faire directement la guerre à la Russie
parce qu'après il y aura le risque
d'être Kobe gérant et d'une escalade et
on voit bien dans quel escalade dans
quel engrenage monsieur selinski veut
nous entraîner vous l'avez tout à fait
dit pour l'instant les armes que nous
livrons ce sont des armes qui permettent
de défendre le territoire la
souveraineté nationale
ukrainienne évidemment si demain ce sont
des avions de combat mais surtout des
missiles de longue portée si demain nous
livrions un messie de longue portée qui
s'abat sur une population russe dans la
profondeur du territoire de la Russie
qu'est-ce qui se passe pensez à seul
instant que Monsieur Poutine ne ferait
rien on serait sans doute entraîné dans
une dans ce cas donc on voit très bien
que on est sur une ligne de crête et je
pense que moi je l'assume totalement
encore une fois l'agresseur
n'envahisseur c'est Vladimir Poutine les
crimes de guerre qui ont été commis ont
été commis par la Russie en tout cas par
un certain nombre d'opérateurs russes
désormais il faut aussi continuer le
bras de fer sans aller trop loin une
dernière question la chaise que vous
demandez un débat au Parlement je pense
que le moment sera bien viendra d'un
débat on en a eu des débats très
régulièrement au Parlement je ne signe
pas que le gouvernement n'est pas fait
droit cette demande du Parlement nous
avons eu déjà deux grands débats au
Parlement sur la question de l'Ukraine
on va parler de la réforme des retraites
puisque là le débat va arriver très vite
au Parlement ça arrivera au mois de mars
au Sénat est-ce que vous allez voter tel
quel la réforme présentait lundi par le
gouvernement nous l'améliorons mais ce
que je veux vous dire c'est que nous
souhaitons que nous votions notre propre
réforme qui sera laquelle la réforme la
réforme qui nous est proposée n'est pas
la réforme de Monsieur Macron c'est la
réforme que le Sénat soutient défend
évoque vous le savez quand même chaque
année depuis 4 ans il y a une
proposition qui est sur la table dans un
dialogue on a réussi en améliorer un
certain nombre de contours je pense aux
petites retraites pour un million 800
000 Français qui sont déjà à la retraite
pour 200 000 Français qui partiront dans
l'avenir chaque année avec leur traite
ils partiront avec 5% du SMIC
1.200 euros c'est important j'ai
toujours dit dans mes rencontres avec
madame la Première ministre que
aujourd'hui c'était les femmes qui
étaient les victimes de notre système de
retraite d'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs pas
seulement de cette réforme parce que ce
sont les femmes qui ont des retraites
qui sont plus petites 75% des petites
retraites ce sont des femmes parce
qu'elles ont des carrières hachées des
carrières incomplètes donc je pense que
il y a des marches sans doute de
manœuvre et nous ferons les femmes sont
un peu pénalis par cette réforme mais
les femmes d'abord le système de
retraite est un miroir de la trajectoire
professionnelle comme la trajectoire
professionnelle des femmes est souvent
incomplète parce qu'elles élèvent des
enfants et bien elles ont été quand
elles partent en retraite plus démunis
que les hommes il y a un paradoxe
puisque le système de retraite par
répartition est un système de solidarité
démographique donc celle qui contribue à
l'équilibre démographique sont celles
qui sont les plus désavantagées donc
nous verrons j'avais fait des
propositions qui pour l'instant n'ont
pas été retenues le gouvernement a
retenu une méthode par exemple qui
consiste à valoriser les congés
parentaux mais il y a des femmes qui ont
pris peu de congé parentaux donc là
encore il y a une inégalité on va
regarder avec nos amis sénateurs René
Paul Savary qui sera notre rapporteur
comment on peut améliorer le système
c'est la seule chose que vous allez
changer il y a pas d'autres choses que
vous allez changer dans cette réforme
forcément améliorer un certain nombre de
points mais je pense qu'il faut à la
fois améliorer la réforme sans la
déséquilibrer parce que l'objectif c'est
quand même de faire en sorte que demain
notre modèle social soit soutenable mais
est-ce que vous n'avez pas la crainte
monsieur Retailleau que il y a une
pression on dit que la poutre a tendance
à trembler puisque les certains députés
semblent se détacher de de leur volonté
de réformes le dernier comptage de Radio
France donnait 16 députés LR qui
pourraient voter contre la réforme cette
s'abstiendrait une vingtaine refuse de
répondre on sent quand même que un doute
s'installe auprès des troupes des
troupes des républicains est-ce que
c'est pas dérangeant moi je pense que la
politique ce sont des convictions et que
la politique s'est apportée du sens à
son action notre conviction ça a
toujours été nous avons toujours porté
des réformes de retraite parce que nous
voulons sauver la sécurité sociale le
modèle par répartition et pourquoi
est-ce que la réforme est indispensable
pour deux raisons il y a deux logiques
qui sont aussi coupantes que des lames
de rasoir le son la logique
démographique il y a de plus en plus de
retraités et de moins en moins de
cotisants il y a un vieillissement et
une dénatalité qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça
c'est quelque chose qui est de l'ordre
c'est indubitable et deuxième logique on
va avoir plus de 150 milliards de
déficits dans 10 ans moi je veux dire la
vérité aux Français si demain on ne fait
rien il y aura un appauvrissement des
retraités et il y aura surtout un
impauvrissement des jeunes générations
on transférera ce fardeau là sur les
jeunes générations qui auront des
retraites de misère et bien évidemment
que une réforme c'est jamais populaire
mais moi mon souci c'est pas d'être
populaire mon souci c'est être utile
pour les Français
il manque de conviction pour vous il a
ses convictions mais je pense que tout
ça illustre en réalité un travail que
nous allons devoir faire dans notre
partie c'est quelle ligne voulant nous
porter c'est un travail de fond je l'ai
souvent dit je pense que il faut
absolument que notre partie notre
famille politique se mette en ordre de
bataille le seul combat qui mérite être
mené c'est le combat des idées il faut
que on travaille cette question là parce
qu'alors on se divisera sur chaque
réforme et sur chaque question sur votre
partie sur votre réforme des retraites
qu'en est-il du groupe au Sénat est-ce
qu'il y a des sénateurs les républicains
qui vous disent on le votera pas cette
réforme pour l'instant on n'est pas du
tout dans la configuration qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale pourquoi parce que
cette réforme on l'a nous forgé ici au
Sénat c'était notre réforme qu'on a
présenté qu'on a voté comme je vous le
disais il y a quelques instants donc il
y a sans doute toujours sur chaque texte
sur chaque texte j'ai une dizaine de
sénateurs quel que soit le texte qui
divergent du groupe c'est normal ça
c'est la vie
ah non c'est parce que je suis en train
de vous dire c'est que ce que je vous
dis c'est que en règle générale sur
chaque texte peu importe le texte il y a
toujours des sénateurs qui ont leur
propre avis non mais c'est pas ce que je
veux dire c'est que le on a nous en
réalité on a voté cette réforme donc
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on va se renier la
politique ce sont les convictions chez
les Sénateurs les républicains qu'on
reçoit le matin et qui nous et qui nous
disent il y a deux choses il y a un les
Français qui sont obligés de travailler
44 ans il y a des sénateurs les
républicains qui disent c'est quand même
problématique et il y a la question du
calendrier pour arriver à 64 ans 2030
pour certains c'est trop rapide et il y
en a aussi qui disent mais ça commence
trop tôt il y a des Français qui sont
proches de la retraite et à qui on va
dire ben non finalement votre retraite
est décalée ça ça pose problème à
certains sénateurs est-ce que ça vous
allez le changer dans le texte on peut
tout examiner et on va commencer on a
commencé déjà le travail on aura un
séminaire ensemble donc on pourra vous
apporter les informations cours du temps
on ne s'interdit rien mais je mets une
limite aussi il faut que cette réforme
soit utile pour qu'elle soit utile il
faut veiller aussi à l'égalité des uns
et des autres à la justice des uns
vis-à-vis des autres et aussi un
équilibre budgétaire
parce que ça ne vous pose pas de ça me
dérange pas de voter le calendrier du
gouvernement 64 ans 2030 pour vous c'est
le bon je pense que 64 ans en 2030 c'est
pas très loin à une année près du
calendrier que nous avions déjà voté ce
que vous pouvez pas vous dire il peut y
avoir une question par exemple du à quel
moment sur quelqu'un de rayé on fait
débuter la réforme il peut y avoir tel
ou tel point mais attention de ne pas
fragiliser les équilibres financiers
c'est remettre en question les retraites
ce que je veux vous dire un point qu'on
ne dit jamais d'ailleurs le système
français est celui qui préserve le plus
nos aînés de la pauvreté est-ce que vous
savez que grâce à notre système vous
avez plus de deux fois moins de
retraités pauvres que de la moyenne des
pays riches de l'OCDE c'est un acquis
qu'il faut conserver et on ne le
conservera qu'à force de courage je
termine pour vous dire qu'en 2030 on
aura le système de retraite en Europe ou
en partie le plus tôt
chez nous c'est 64 ans dans la grande
totalité des pays européens la grande
noyade en tout cas ce sera 67 ans et on
aura sans doute le système de carrière
longue le plus avantageux d'Europe alors
simplement un avis sur sur ce que
réclame également le président des Hauts
de France Xavier Bertrand il était sur
LCI et il disait par contre qu'il
fallait en finir d'ici la fin de la
décennie avec les régimes spéciaux qui
est un peu le l'oublier pour l'instant
de la réforme des retraites plutôt que
de s'en remettre à une clause du
grand-père qui renverrait finalement la
fin des régimes spéciaux à 43 ans et
est-ce que vous aussi vous réclamez que
on sait le sort des des régimes spéciaux
plutôt moi c'est une demande que je
comprends tout à fait j'avais insisté
pour que le décalage de deux ans sur le
privé soit aussi supporté aussi bien par
la fonction publique que par les régimes
spéciaux mais nous votion nous aussi
dans la réforme que nous proposions au
Sénat une convergence sur un certain
nombre d'années de ces régions spéciaux
c’est-à-dire que nous ne proposions pas
la clause grand-père je pense que je
préférerais moi par exemple et nous
l'étudierons pourquoi pas que on puisse
avoir cette trajectoire qui permette de
rapprocher justement les régimes
spéciaux du régime général de la
Sécurité sociale parce qu'il y a une
injustice regardez la RATP ou on parle
des régimes où on parle le plus tôt où
on a une retraite moyenne qui est l'une
des plus élevées est-ce que tout ça est
juste est-ce que ça risque pas
d'entraîner une colère supplémentaire
sachant que déjà l'Inter syndicale et
extrêmement
véhémente concernant le projet de
réforme alors elle indique qu'elle veut
me voir multiplier les actions d'ici le
la nouvelle journée de mobilisation le
31 janvier la CGT chemineau et SUD-Rail
annonce quant à elle qu'elles vont faire
elles appellent à la grève les 7 et 8
février juste avant les vacances
scolaires est-ce que vous regrettez
cette cette menace pour les vacances des
Français
il y a deux choses il y a le droit de
grève il est constitutionnel je pense
bien évidemment que sur une réforme qui
est aussi lourde le droit de grève il
est reconnu donc il doit jouer en
revanche de l'autre côté ce que je
n'admets pas c'est la prise en otage du
pays je fais une proposition et je la
mets sur la table ce matin au
gouvernement j'ai fait voter il y a près
de trois ans un texte au Sénat sur un
vrai service public minimum c'était quoi
c'était de concentrer sur les heures de
pointe de la journée deux heures le
matin deux heures le soir les jours
ouvrés un tiers du trafic quotidien là
on peut à la fois concilier le droit de
grève et la continuité des services
publics et la liberté des gens des
Françaises et des Français d'aller au
travail le service minimum que nous
avons en France et simplement un droit
et un devoir d'information du salarié
vis-à-vis de l'entreprise est contourner
avec des préavis de grève qui
s'enchaînent les uns aux autres il y a
mille façons de contourner ce dispositif
moi je propose un vrai service minimum
concentré sur le travail l'Italie par
exemple à concentré sur les jours de
vacances moi je pense que il faut
d'abord assurer une continuité service
public lorsque les Français vantent au
travail et je termine comment vouloir en
France dire aux Français il faut pour
des raisons climatiques
prendre justement des transports
collectifs qui sont moins polluants et
ne pas assurer à ces Français une
robustesse justement dans la continuité
de ces services publics collectifs mais
vous dites au gouvernement reprenez mon
texte à votre compte et faites-en un
projet de là où est-ce que vous allez
reproposer ce texte Sénat il est voté il
est voté
c'est une proposition
j'ai connu des textes que j'avais moi
proposé par exemple sur les black blocks
qui pourrissait vous savez
avec leur ultra-violence les
manifestations je l'avais fait voter au
sedum ce Castaner était totalement
contre un jour mois de janvier je suis
dans la télé et j'entends monsieur
Édouard Philippe à l'époque dire bah on
va reprendre finalement le texte aussi
texte en tout cas peu importe si c'est
Mentax mais il faut un dispositif
robuste pour assurer aux français qu'on
ne les prenne pas en otage régulièrement
puisqu'on est sur le le parlementaire le
gouvernement a choisi de passer par le
47 ans c'est cet article qui bloque le
temps d'examen d'un texte au Parlement
c'est une erreur
non enfin c'est une erreur
avec un temps d'examen classique
la faute c'est l'obstruction
parlementaire je veux dire que on a une
Constitution de la Cinquième République
ma filiation égoïste donc ces
institutions me vont très bien j'observe
que même avec le 47 ans le temps que
l'on disposera l'Assemblée pour discuter
du texte est un temps qui sera même plus
important que celui qu'elle avait dont
elle avait disposé sur un texte plus
classique pour la réforme de 2010 avec
cette difficulté que il y a une crainte
que le Conseil constitutionnel puisse
retoquer cette formule mais je comprends
pas
c'est dans la je veux pas comment le
Conseil constitutionnel irait dire qu'un
article de la Constitution est un
constitutionnel non non ce qui serait
inconstitutionnel je vais vous dire
ce qui serait un constitutionnel c'est
que on met dans le texte précisément des
dispositions sur le code du travail qui
n'auraient pas de conséquences sur le
financement des Saliers des sociétés là
bien sûr ce serait l'article 45
absolument je vois que vous êtes bons
conditionnaliste ce sera cavalier
législatif on va parler de la
contestation Julien oui parce que ça
croit chez les français malgré l'effort
de pédagogie formulées par le
gouvernement 72% ils sont opposés selon
le dernier sondage ELAB qu'est-ce que
vous leur dites à ces Français qui
visiblement alors soit ils comprennent
pas la réforme ils sont et surtout
est-ce que vous ne craignez pas de faire
les les frais de cette impopularité en
étant associé à un projet qu'on nomme
maintenant dans l'opposition bornes
cioti alors désolé c'était presque borne
Retailleau aussi ça aurait pu être peu
importe je revendique que rien sur ce
texte là pour moi la politique ce sont
les convictions je pense qu'on aurait
tout à perdre à nous renier
et la droite a beaucoup perdu à se
renier toute l'histoire de la droite
depuis 30 ans c'est 10 millions même pas
d'ailleurs des 10 millions d'électeurs
qu'on a perdu c'est depuis 2007 pourquoi
on les a perdu parce qu'on sait René la
politique c'est de la constance et je
pense que pour moi on ne doit pas viser
une popularité et je mets en garde cette
droite qui veut être populaire pour moi
une droite populaire c'est une droite
qui dit la vérité aux Français ça n'est
pas une droite qui place au dessus de
tout critères sa popularité ça c'est de
la démagogie et sur le plan de la
démagogie on n'ira jamais suffisamment
loin parce que Madame Le Pen Monsieur
Mélenchon nous donc voulons toujours sur
ce registre là première chose donc
soyons constants ensuite c'est une
réforme qui est très compliquée je vous
assure que une réforme des retraites je
me suis beaucoup penché depuis plusieurs
années c'est un monstre technique donc
je crois que petit à petit il faut que
on fasse œuvre de pédagogie le débat
parlementaire va servir aussi à éclairer
un certain nombre de questions est-ce
que le gouvernement un tel exercice de
pédagogie le gouvernement raté deux
choses Emmanuel Macron en soutenant
pendant des années que il ne fallait pas
bouger là je l'égal à 62 ans s'étirer
une balle dans le pied voilà il a fait
la girouette et en politique c'est
jamais bon première chose deuxièmement
un certain nombre de ministres y compris
d'ailleurs le président de la République
au début a présenté cette réforme comme
nécessaire en réalité pour soit une
trajectoire bruxellesoise ou soit pour
faire des économies ou soit pour
utiliser l'argent public sur d'autres
points et ça ça jetait le double alors
ensuite la première mise à rectifier le
tir mais c'était déjà un petit peu trop
tard donc je pense que rien n'est perdu
encore une fois cette réforme elle est
nécessaire parce que si on ne la fait
pas on aura un système à deux vitesses
les riches feront la capitalisation et
les pauvres auront des retraites de
misère parler des républicains
en effet les républicains on a compris
qu'il y avait quand même eu quand même
quelques difficultés à proposer
l'organigramme de du parti Éric Ciotti
visiblement a dû essayer de concilier
mais ça c'est pas très bien passé alors
on avait 65 membres sur cette grande
feuille avec l'organigramme on est passé
même à 69 membres alors certains ont
parlé d'armée mexicaine d'armée des
Indes on vous a senti très énervé
vis-à-vis de la répartition des postes
est-ce que c'est apaisé dorénavant oui
je considère qu'il y a une difficulté
effectivement j'avais deux objectifs moi
c'est que 1 j'ai fait pratiquement un
électeur sur deux donc si on veut
rassembler la famille politique il
fallait envoyer des signaux vis-à-vis de
ces électeurs qui m'ont soutenus moi je
portais un projet de renouvellement et
un projet de rupture je pense que c'est
les deux conditions pour rebâtir quelque
chose de crédible voilà mais fallait
donner ces signes là et deuxième chose
le Sénat qui est le premier groupe
parlementaire a souvent été assez
maltraité dans l'organisation et dans
les instances de notre partie nous
étions très largement sous représentés
donc je portais aussi bien d'ailleurs
avec Gérard Larcher ces deux points là
c'est à dire la justice un équilibre et
puis aussi faire en sorte que le Sénat
et les sénateurs soient mieux pris en
compte
c'est réglé pour l'instant on aura une
autre phase attendez c'est réglé sur
l'exécutif il y aura ensuite le Bureau
politique et la commission nationale
d'investiture qui donneront lieu sans
doute et ils ont déjà donné lieu
ensemble de discussion parce que là
aussi je veux que les équilibres soient
défendus c'est une condition du
rassemblement malgré votre énervement
vous vous étiez là mardi soir on veut
direction à ses côtés on le voit sur ces
images Aurélien Pradier lui n'était pas
la serre gretables oui
il aurait dû être là j'aurais préféré
qu'il soit là c'est un mauvais message
qu'il envoie au moment où vous voulez
afficher l'unité de jacksony vous lui
demanderez vous lui demanderez
simplement il peut pas y avoir de
trajectoire personnelle je pense que la
vie politique c'est plutôt un sport
d'équipe je sais très bien que les
dessins individuels comptent beaucoup
mais on peut pas dans la difficulté dans
laquelle nous sommes nous sommes dans
une situation d'extrême faiblesse les
trois dernières élections
présidentielles nous les avons perdus et
la dernière à moins de 5%. donc pensez à
un seul instant qu'on peut se sauver
seul que on peut ne pas porter des
convictions communes je pense que c'est
une illusion juste un dernier mot
là-dessus parce que Erik sotti dans une
interview Figaro dit vous avoir proposé
une responsabilité majeure à la tête du
parti je le cite laquelle et pourquoi
l'avoir refusé non depuis le début j'ai
dit erikiotique je ne demandais rien
pour moi-même pour la bonne et simple
raison que comme président de groupe je
suis dans toutes les instances donc moi
j'ai pas besoin d'un titre il vous
proposez quoi il m'avait proposé de
présider le nationale bon donc
c'est une belle grande responsabilité
mais voyez tous les matins embrasant
c'est pas la première responsabilité à
laquelle je pense donc non je voulais
encore une fois que on puisse donner de
vrais signaux de rassemblement mais la
question aujourd'hui est plus celle-là
c'est maintenant qu'elle ligne comment
travaille-t-on sur le fond
[Musique]
écoutez ce texte là il y a une question
et une seule pour laquelle on va
l'apprécier est-ce que il reprend le
contrôle des fruits migratoires
aujourd'hui certainement pas pourquoi
parce que il y a le en même temps
comment voulez-vous satisfaire le
rapporteur général du texte qui est en
même temps à l'Assemblée nationale le
député qui préside la commission des
lois monsieur Sacha Houlier qui
représente l'algorge du macronisme avec
nos propres propositions en d'autres
termes ce texte-là aujourd'hui
il crée des régularisations massives
avec à la fois ce titre pour les métiers
en tension tous les métiers sont en
tension et avec le rattrapage un
deuxième guichet pour notamment les
demandeurs d'Asie qu'est-ce qu'on
constate que les frontières de l'Europe
ont été franchis dans des proportions
jamais vu cette année pratiquement
depuis 2015 plus 64% de franchissement
de clandestins qu'est-ce qu'on constate
en France en 2021 nous avons record un
record 270
000 premiers titres de séjour un nouveau
record on l'a pris hier près de 155 000
demandeurs d'asile donc vous voyez bien
qu'on ne va pas résister et ça n'est que
le commencement je veux simplement
redire à nos auditeurs au
téléspectateurs que l'Europe c'est la
moitié de la dépense sociale mondiale
mais que ça n'est que 6% de la
population quand je suis né il y avait
300 millions d'Africains en 2050 demain
il y en aura 2 milliards et demi on est
à l'orée de grands mouvements or ce
texte là ça n'est pas un vélo ce que je
propose moi ce que nous proposons c'est
d'arrêter les pompes aspirantes par
exemple les titres pour les étrangers
malades vous rendez compte que l'an
dernier 5000 étrangers qui viennent
n'ont pas des pays pauvres du G20 on en
bénéficié en France on est le plus
avantageux des pays d'Europe sur ce
droit justement à l'excès aux soins
gratuits sur les demandes d'asile sur
regroupant fam ça doit changer
clairement sans
changer l'orientation il sera
aujourd'hui
inconcevable ça sera le 20 le 22ème loi
22e texte en 30 ans pour ne rien changer
pour faire semblant de changer nous
ferons des propositions j'en fais
quelques-unes aujourd'hui par exemple
qu'un clandestin qui franchirait la
frontière illégalement en France il doit
être persuadé que jamais il sera
régularisé merci Bruno Retailleau merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité